I'm Carrie empower I'm an entrepreneur
I'm and the Dead Sea World Economic
Forum in 2011 looking at the challenges
that the Arab world faces in terms of
growth certainly there are there's a lot
that can be done first and foremost by
governments to allow for the private
sector to excel and to be able to create
the opportunities in order to do so the
government has to reduce the bureaucracy
that is currently cycling growth there
has to be also availability or access to
investments that continue to grow the
private sector so that they in turn
create those needed jobs there needs to
be a partnership between the private
sector and education so that
universities mostly can provide the
needed skills and talents that the
private sector is working for to employ
certainly this region holds a lot of
potential for growth and promise we have
seen the Arab Spring take shape
we are optimistic that the future will
be bright and prosperous one for the
Middle East